YouTube arrow is back so this is gonna
be my episode 16 video just careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen it yet
always love when Cupid's around off her
meds unmedicated Cupid is the best
version of Cupid so because they're
really just like a couple big things
going on in this episode I'm gonna do
top five WTF I'll explain the easter
eggs as we go along there were a couple
Easter eggs well let's start with number
5 the trial of damian darhk-- kind of
reminds me of the trial of the punisher
that's happening on daredevil right now
so just careful for spoilers for
daredevil real quick you've probably
seen this episode but Marc Guggenheim
showrunner for arrow used to be a lawyer
before he became a writer so he's either
worked on legal based shows shows about
lawyers or written things like that into
a lot of his episodes across the years
one of the comics that he wrote was a
Punisher story about The Punisher being
put on trial that's part of daredevil
season 2 if you haven't watched that you
should check it out it's really cool
what a coincidence that the same week
the daredevil does a story that Marc
Guggenheim wrote about a big comic book
character being put on trial arrow also
does an episode where they put a big
villain on trial but the people that
wrote this episode are actually two
production interns I think our
production assistants so surprisingly it
was actually a pretty tight episode some
of the dialogue didn't work for me like
Erin writer had some really cheesy
dialogue in the flashbacks but otherwise
despite the fact that it was written by
two really inexperienced writers I felt
like it was a pretty decent episode in
the way they explained it this trial is
going to carry across the next couple of
episodes damian darhk-- is going to be
in prison until the trial so a little
while ago they posted a teaser with
Merlyn visiting damian darhk-- in prison
look we'll just see that over the next
couple of episodes episode 19 is
supposed to be a big WTF so I don't know
if that's gonna happen before the trial
or after the trial it might happen
before because usually when a big
villain is going on trial somebody dies
before that trial happens so that they
aren't there to give testimony Marc
Guggenheim did say that Laurel was going
to try to prosecute damian darhk-- we'll
see how that plays out there are a
number of different things that they've
teased that might prevent that stray
observations though damien darhk's
attorney looks a lot like the attorney
that represented the drug dealers in the
wire Marc Guggenheim is a big wire fan
so you would not be wrong and drawing
some parallels from the why
- arrow arrow season 1 is actually a
good example of DC TV doing their
version of The Wire but number 4 to beat
the up Cupid his back she has been
discharged from the Suicide Squad so
it's not like they're after her she's
served her tour of duty
so they've released her back into
society but the way the producers
explain it that because of being spurned
by the arrow her experience with Oliver
and that that unrequited love in the
death of Deadshot she's has been
completely twisted
so she's killing newlyweds number 3 WTF
the idol that Baron Reiter is going for
in the secret cave is the same idol that
damian darhk-- was using in present day
that they smashed in her earlier episode
total Raiders of the Lost Ark moment I
was waiting for him to make Oliver take
it off the stand but it turns out that
you have to kill someone to power it
it's powered by people's life force so
my first thought was Full Metal
Alchemist and using a blood rune like
drawing a blood rune so that you could
reach the game but I don't really think
arrow was going for that but it is fun
to think there might be a few riders on
the arrow staff that are full metal fans
number two WTF the fake olicity wedding
so I'm sure a lot of you that are big
fans of them being together probably
cried a little bit Oliver's vows were
the vows that he wrote for the wedding
he thought they were going to have
Felicity's she just wrote on the spot
and it was all about you know light and
dark love being light and it really did
sound like pure fanfiction which is why
if you did roll your eyes into the back
of your head you should fix them because
she explains later that it was all
[ __ ] she's like that that doesn't
apply to us she was just saying that in
the moment but maybe like a little part
of her actually believes it the way they
explained it at the end of the episode
and the stuff that's going on with
damien darhk's trial I feel are really
big foreshadowing for what's gonna
happen at the end of the season we know
someone is going to die
I feel like Felicity is just gonna go
away like she'll still work with team
arrow she's just not gonna stand right
next to Oliver all the time when someone
on the team dies that is going to bring
her back like that'll bring them back
together and catalyze the group but for
the next couple of episodes it's just
gonna be like the way she explained at
the end of the episode I can't be right
here next to you all the time so some of
you have asked me if they killed Alyssa
T and it depends on what you consider
that to be like Oliver is still gonna
care about her so you could say that
it's still alive but usually when I used
the term
see I'm talking about their actual
physical relationship whether they're
going out they're engaged they're
getting married that is not a thing
right now but if you're one of the many
very divisive people on it that doesn't
mean that it won't be happening in the
future if you remember they let Lois get
married to Clark on Smallville but when
did that wedding actually happen in one
of the very last episodes of the series
so while I'm very happy that nobody's
getting married right now because
Felicity's speech does a really good job
of explaining why they can't get married
and she's not taking crazy pills like
Cupid or anything like that living the
life of a hero there's always gonna be
some situation where he'll be forced to
do something that will go against their
relationship so Felicity's choice is the
choice of reason but it's one of those
things where you know in order to stay
interesting you still need sexual
tension so when they get together and
they're all lovey-dovey that kind of
goes away there isn't really tension
anymore
now that they're apart you'll get more
of that season 1 season 2 vibe where
they care about each other like she said
that she loves them but they're not
actually together but the number one WTF
is that this whole case against damian
darhk-- rests on Laurel and Quentin you
know all the people to end in the grave
it's really coming back to them even if
you've looked at the spoilers from the
set there are there things that make it
seem like a certain character might end
up dying there was so much loaded
dialogue in this episode like Quentin
saying I might be putting a match to my
career that just makes me feel like
someone's gonna get burned to death like
the character on Team arrow that ends up
dying will end up burning to death and
that's why they won't be able to come
back because there'll be a pile of ashes
but you guys let me know in the comments
just based on the things that people
said the dialogue in this episode
especially during the trial who do you
think is gonna end up in the grave just
remember that there are gonna be a
couple more episodes before that person
does die so you just have to pay very
close attention to the things that
people save for the next couple of weeks
but real quick reminder there's a new
round of the DC giveaway happening right
now it's to IMAX give certificates to
Batman V Superman all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video I'm gonna do a
trailer video for the flash I'll
announce the winner whenever I post that
that'll probably be on Friday but
actually I almost forgot markovia the
city that they mentioned that this
damian darhk-- or
under person is from I thought it was
hilarious that they called him bender
markovia is a place that they've used on
arrow before as a fictional Eastern Bloc
country where villains come from it's
kind of like a different version of
corto Maltese corto Maltese is just like
a port of call for villains in the DC
universe so there's just a name drop for
a place in the comics in a place that
they've used in the past on arrow
why you guys wait for my next video to
post you can click here for last night's
episode of the flash if you haven't seen
it yet and you can click here for my
last daredevil video I just posted thank
you so much watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you